all right um thank you all so much for
joining today I'm excited to briefly
meet you all and chat a little bit more
about the ignite program happening this
summer
so my name is Kelsey I'm the associate
director for ignite programs here at
Stanford GSB I've actually been running
ignite programs for seven years now at
this I believe will be my 20th so this
is what I love to do I really enjoy
getting to work with entrepreneurs and
innovators and support you all as you
you know work on your ideas and you know
experience this educational time at the
GSB
the program is also directed by yossi
Feinberg he has been running ignite for
much longer than I am and he's really
the brains behind the curriculum and the
assignments that sort of structure the
program he teaches a number of sessions
in ignite so you'll get to know him well
during the time that you're on campus
this summer for the program
the other part of our ignite program
team is Jay Yang Feng she is our program
manager and she and I together manage
all of the logistics and coordination of
the program
foreign
ite in a nutshell is a rigorous academic
program that teaches you the
fundamentals of business and practical
aspects of developing an innovative
ideas and driving them forward so what
that really means is that our goal as a
program is to give you this toolkit that
you can use to launch ideas or develop
ideas that you have during the program
and in the future to achieve that goal
we bring in typically a dozen of some of
the most experienced faculty at the GSB
so the folks who are pictured at the
bottom of the slide are four of those
professors who teach in the program
three of those are actually senior
associate Deans so the most senior title
available at business school so we're
extremely fortunate to get to work with
some of the what I think are the best
faculty that I have access to and you
know they come in and teach their MBA or
MSX content but really whittled down to
only a three-hour session and focused on
what they think that entrepreneurs and
innovators need most from the you know
broad topic of something like accounting
yeah
in the program we have a few different
buckets of content so the first are the
Core Business skills that you probably
think about when you think about a
business education these are things like
marketing operations
Finance economics the really kind of
hard skills so to speak
we also have a component of Applied
skills things like negotiation and
pitching and teamwork that are also
super important to have if you plan to
become an entrepreneur or you know
whatever you plan to do in your career
those applied skills are always valuable
like I mentioned earlier a lot of this
content is sort of a an excerpt of what
is taught in the MBA program so the
faculty are teaching you know case
studies that they are deeply familiar
with but they're really tailoring the
focus to entrepreneurship and Innovation
so you'll notice we don't actually have
a lot of Entrepreneurship focused
classes in the program it's marketing
for entrepreneurs operations for
entrepreneurs we will also have an
entrepreneurship class and a design
thinking or prototyping class to really
dive into the entrepreneurial specific
content there
in addition to all of this classroom
education we also have a team Venture
project so that sort of goes alongside
the classroom learning to make sure that
you're getting an opportunity to
reinforce what you're learning from the
professors by applying it to what feels
like a real world venture
we want to make sure that you leave not
only with academic knowledge but also
with practical knowledge and experience
that will help you make the best use of
what you're learning in ignite
support these team projects
it will pair each team with a mentor who
has industry or startup experience that
can help you yossi who I mentioned
earlier will do check-ins with the teams
every week to make sure that you're
getting a small group feedback on your
projects and we'll have a number of
assignments and other sort of structured
components to make sure that you're
getting the pacing of the project and
really getting the most out of this
Venture experience
at the end of the program each team will
pitch to a panel of VCS and experienced
entrepreneurs not for funding but for
feedback and advice on their projects as
well as more generally the
entrepreneurship component
in addition to the faculty that already
teach at the GSB we bring in a number of
guest speakers and panelists and
different business experts who have less
academic and more real-world experience
that they can bring in we'll bring in IP
lawyers alumni Stanford ignite alumni
who are now successful entrepreneurs and
other folks who can really make sure
that you're getting a well-rounded
picture of the entrepreneurship and
Innovation education
so real quick I do want to touch on
covid-19 precautions as I'm sure you're
all aware these are rapidly evolving so
I fully expect that some of these will
change by the time you actually get here
this summer for now I can everyone is
required to be fully vaccinated and I do
not expect that to change that can be
any who approved vaccine just want to
make sure that you're all aware of that
well in advance
we currently require masks indoors that
may or may not be the case in the summer
and there may be additional sort of
testing or forms that you would be
required to
to complete as part of our covid
precautions
our primary goal you know is of course
make sure you have a positive
educational experience this summer and
part of that is you know of course
making sure that you're safe and
everyone is able to attend the program
in full
jumping back to the more fun part uh the
program benefits that we hope that you
walk away with
one of these is learning the language of
business
especially for folks who are coming from
non-business fields we want to make sure
that whatever you decide to do after
ignite whether it's launching a startup
or moving into a career in industry or
moving into a more business focused side
of your current industry that you have
the language that you need to be able to
sit down at that table and make an
impact
and to also make sure that you kind of
know what you don't know
none of the you know if you want to
become an expert in marketing the three
hours that are provided in ignite are
not going to be all the marketing you
ever need it's going to be enough to
make sure that you know what you're
interested in what knowledge you're
looking for and how to find that
knowledge in addition to really
establishing a strong foundation in each
of these topics
we'll also kind of make sure you have
the skills to turn an idea into a
successful Venture so you are working on
a project during ignite and some of
these are real world startup ideas that
may move forward as companies after the
program however a lot of the Venture
projects aren't and that's totally okay
too the goal is primarily for that to be
a learning experience so that you walk
away with a toolkit that you can sort of
run a mini ignite uh Yoshi likes to say
on your on whatever future ideas and
projects you have after you have left
Sanford
we also want to make sure that you
improve your teamwork leadership and
public speaking skills those are
certainly something that you'll need no
matter you know which post ignite path
do you choose to take
and an additional benefit is the network
that you can develop while at ignite
you'll have your cohort and we'll put
together a number of networking and
social activities to ensure that you're
getting to really build those
connections and leave with that strong
community of your ignite cohort
you'll also have access to the global
Stanford ignite alumni community of
approximately 3 000 participants from
the last
15 years
so you know that's another Network that
you can tap into as well as folks like
mentors and panelists that you meet
along the way
the ignite participant profile is
typically fairly diverse our goal is to
have you in the classroom with people
who are like-minded entrepreneurs but
from different backgrounds and
experiences than what you yourself have
had
we'll try to make sure that each Venture
team has a diverse group of participants
so that you have the most different kind
of points of view and perspectives to
make sure that you're learning the most
out of the program
we have a number of participants who
come from leading companies this is a
short list of folks who come in the past
and we also have various stages of
entrepreneurs whether they're you know
folks who are preparing to launch
something or people who are already
running a small business
we'll have local and international
working professionals so if you were in
the Bay Area great if you are not you're
also welcome to apply to ignatic and
come travel to the Silicon Valley for
the program
and then on the Stanford side we
typically are able to get grad students
and postdocs from all of the Stanford
schools and at various levels so again
our goal is to expose you to people who
are outside of the community that you
maybe already are working or studying in
um and roughly 80 percent of our
participants do have an advanced degree
however it is not a requirement
so the program this summer is going to
run from June 25th through July 19th and
during that time you'll have class every
day every weekday from 9 40 a.m to 5
o'clock P.M
in addition to that you will also have
that Venture team project which
primarily takes place outside of the
official classroom hours so during the
four weeks that ignite runs if you do
wind up participating in the program you
should plan to be spending a significant
chunk of time outside of regular class
hours working with your Venture team and
working on case studies things like that
in order to get the most out of the
program we typically do recommend that
people you know clear their schedules as
much as possible to make sure that you
can really spend the time in team
meetings working on assignments to make
sure that when you do pitch to BCS at
the end of the program you're proud of
the product that you have created and
that you've learned you know as much as
possible out of the program
we'll also have a pre-programmed portion
that happens fully online and that will
start May 25th so that's the time period
in which you'll get to start meeting
each other reviewing case studies and
also that you'll pitch ideas to be
considered to be Venture projects in the
program
the standard cost of attendance is 14
950 dollars
and we are able to offer it at a
discounted rate for current Stanford
students and post docs thanks to a
generous subsidy from vpge
so that 500 tuition is available to
folks who are either
who either will be an active grad
student or postdoc during the program or
who graduate or complete their
postdoctoral appointment in Spring
quarter of this year unfortunately we
don't have discounts for Stanford staff
faculty or alumni
and then at the end of the program
you'll receive a certificate of
participation so there are no grades or
academic hours but you will receive your
certificate the proofs that you
completed all of the program Milestones
you know were attend attended class and
we're an active participant really you
know fully participated in the ignite
program
we do try to cap the cohort at 72 to
make sure that you have meaningful group
interaction so the cohort size can vary
a little bit year to year but typically
expect to see 70 72 folks in the program
[Music]
um so it is a competitive program we are
currently accepting applications but
admission decisions won't go out until
after the deadline to make sure that the
admissions committee can fully review
all of the applicants and make sure
they're choosing the best possible
cohort for the summer
the application deadline is April 13th
so you have about a month left
and it's going to quickly go over some
of the components of that application
so the online application form includes
everything that you need to submit there
will be short essays resume professional
recommendation and an online video
interview
for the recommendation
you know you're free to choose whoever
you feel will you know be your best
Advocate as you apply for the program a
lot of people who are currently at
Stanford choose a an advisor or
potentially you know someone from
someone that you're working with closely
if you're a non-stanford participant
you're free to choose a professor if you
recently graduated or a colleague or
manager or you know whoever a current
kind of Mentor in your life would be the
most important thing is that this is
someone who can speak to who you are as
a person and a teammate and ideally you
can also speak to your entrepreneurial
or innovation related ambitions
the online video interview is also
recorded through the application portal
so instead of having to come in for an
interview later it all happens in one go
for the interview you'll have a chance
to practice as much as you'd like before
you complete the actual interview
recording but once you start the
interview recording much like a live in
person interview you only get one shot
at answering each question
that sometimes that you feel anxious
don't worry the admissions committee is
fully aware that that can sometimes you
know be a little bit stressful and are
you know they're able to kind of look
around that for your interview but just
do be aware that once you start the
formal interview that's a you know get
one shot at recording those videos and
our goal is to make sure that we're then
getting as close as possible to an
in-person interview experience as we can
without actually having to do in-person
interviews
um so the admissions committee will
review all of those different elements
together and share admission decisions
typically early May late April or early
May
and with that that actually is the end
of my presentation so I'm going to go
ahead and stop sharing and have the
panel hop on and introduce themselves
so today I'm joined by three of our past
igniters from the full-time 2022 program
and so I'm going to have the three of
you go ahead and introduce yourselves
what you were working on before ignite
kind of what brought you to the ignite
program and then what you've been up to
since ignite
I guess so Hill we'll start with you
hi everyone
um I'm Sohail I was part of the
full-time ignite cohort last summer
summer of 2022 and um I'm a PhD student
at Stanford electrical engineering
department
um the reason that I joined ignite last
summer was that I had no background in
entrepreneurship so
um I'm a technical person I had no
non-technical skills uh that are needed
for entrepreneurship and then wanted to
get
um a shallow but steep understanding of
the entire area
um and uh the experience that I had was
uh very positive
because
I was joined with other people that had
similar passion people that uh usually
do full-time ignite
um they care enough about
entrepreneurship to actually dedicate at
least one month
to this program
yeah and uh one suggestion that I have
for uh anybody that wants to join ignite
is that uh take the first few days of
the program very seriously
because if you know I wasn't sure if I
wanted to suggest my own idea or want to
work on someone else's idea but I'm very
happy that I actually suggested my own
idea and I
it happened that many people liked it
and we got a team together and we could
work on it
thank you
I think you are a silencer yes thanks
um Julia will go to you next to
introduce yourself
good thank you Kelsey uh hi everyone I'm
Julia I'm from Brazil I joined uh Sohail
in taiba my dearest colleagues on East
Sanford ignite Program full time 2022.
it was a very nice experience actually
one of the nicest experiences I have
ever had in terms of academic program
and on Hands-On learning
I came to ignite I applied to ignite
because I wanted I I work on product
management and I worked as a product
manager when I joined in United but I
came I come originally from a Lego
background so I wanted I had recently
shift careers and I wanted to have a
more in-depth knowledge of Business and
Entrepreneurship especially
I work in a fintech in Brazil so it was
kind of nice to have the sense of
Silicon Valley as well companies and and
I don't know and scenario of the Bay
Area
I'm now when I came back actually I got
promoted some months later
um I think ignite helped me that because
I did some very nice things about
thinking differently I think professors
and students did things differently at
ignite and help you think differently
and then I got promoted to head of
department so it was a pretty nice
experience
um because of that too the advice that I
had to actually balance the demands and
and what to focus when you were there
maybe
take I think similar to so he'll take
the full time to be there uh don't do ex
like I'll I'll try to I don't know go
there and continue with my job I took
three weeks vacation which was something
that I have never done before it was
kind of pretty big for me but it was the
best decision ever because I was
completely there I still talked to my uh
group my Venture group my adventure idea
group I advise them on something that
they're doing right now so it was like a
long last uh lasting relationship that I
got from there because I was completely
focused on that so it was a pretty good
one and
and that's what I I would say also for
advice that I I wish I had done before
like uh don't worry too much about work
what's happening in your current company
or something like that just focus on
doing this one-time experience that you
will have with amazing an amazing cohort
and that's it yeah
thank you um and then table we're on to
you
yeah so hi everyone my name is taiba I
basically prior to ignite I recently
graduated so I have a different story
like it's not like Julie or so here so I
just graduated and I from undergrad and
I wanted to kick start my career in
entrepreneurship I had this idea of
creating an edtech startup so I applied
to Stanford ignite
and prior to ignite I was also working I
just had two months of work experience I
was working at as an equity research
analyst at an investment Bank
post ignite I was able to learn the role
as a corporate Venture analyst a
telejustice firm
and also I joined the health Tech
startup based in Abu Dhabi where I'm
mostly more involved on the marketing
side of the business so that was my
experience for stignite as you could see
like it was actually valuable to
kick-starting my career trajectory and
the second thing I would talk about I
would like to talk about is balancing
the demands I took time off
to just fully focus on Stanford ignite
and actually
really focus on the elements the
curriculum that professor yossi and the
other faculty member teach because it
was really valuable to me uh especially
in the role as I work in corporate
Venture Capital everything that we
learned during the program was really
applicable to my role and disclaimer I
actually refer back to these like the
uoc's framework of the ignite framework
during my work during my work actually
and advice I could give like to Future
participants is don't beat yourself up
when it comes to your startup ideas
learn to Pivot and don't get too
attached to your startup ideas and
another thing I have I had in mind is I
came into the program I wanted an exit
route and to being an entrepreneur but
that did not happen so I was open to
other ideas such as for example what
would it be
and how would things look like if I was
on the investment side so I tried to dig
through this and that's the beauty of
standard ignite is you have this
curriculum that helps you evaluate
business decisions from looking at it
from an investor standpoint as well as
an entrepreneurial standpoint so you get
a holistic view you get a comprehensive
View and so whatever Etc whatever
pathway you have in mind it's very
flexible post ignite and that's like a
real life example like working in BC
like and the materials and the
curriculum I think that's where I'm at
right now
well thank you all um for for yeah for
sharing um so much advice and
introducing yourselves we'll actually
open up to questions from
um from everybody at this point so feel
free to uh raise your hand or mute
yourself and
um you can unmute and ask a question of
the panelists or of myself do you have a
more logistical question you would like
answered if you're not able to unmute
you can also enter a question in the
chat and I will read it aloud
I had a question Kelsey is are the
applications currently rolling is there
an advantage to applying earlier as
opposed to later
so there aren't ruling Admissions and
there won't be an advantage to applying
early versus just before the deadline I
definitely
recommend not waiting until the very
last minute just in case there's
especially if the video interviews that
can sometimes take longer than people
expect but certainly you're free to keep
editing and updating until you know a
couple days before the deadline and that
won't be held against you in any way
thank you and then my other question was
I I'm assuming that there's a mix of
current Stanford students and
non-stanford students can you give me an
insight as to like how what the balance
is yeah so in the summer we tend to have
more Stanford uh Stanford folks just
because of the way that the schedule is
um I would say in the summer we
typically have about 80 Stanford and 20
non-stanford participants
um you know give or take
thank you
what other questions can I um Can the
panelists or myself answer hi Kelsey
this is Raj uh Raj Goyle how are you I
see some of the people that come from
abroad who do not have uh accommodation
uh at Stanford so what what uh what are
those options you have for students who
are traveling from abroad or from
different parts of the country
sure so we do actually have
um on-campus housing available that once
you are admitted to the program you'll
receive a form to apply for that there
typically isn't I don't think anyone
gets rejected from that there typically
is plenty of capacity
um or Julia I don't know if either of
you stayed in the student housing and
could speak to that
I think taiba didn't because I remember
that but I I did I stayed at Munger
house because I went with my husband so
we wanted a couple's house a couple
housing which was not available for the
evgr which was the most
um like commonplace for people from
England program because it's closer to
GSB so most of people go there and stay
at evgr I think I was the only one that
stayed at Monger but it didn't change in
terms of like interaction and or nothing
the thing about Internationals and
people that come from abroad is that you
get you get very tight with everyone you
get a very nice network of people
because they live together literally
like in the same building and there's a
taipa was one that she didn't live there
visual all the time she was there with
us because we we was we were there for
the first time uh sometimes at Stanford
and we wanted to know the Bay Area it
was first time for most of us so for an
international applicant or candidate or
someone that's doing program I really
recommend it and I really recommend that
you stay uh in the housing options
because they're great and you get like
more this sense of community and and
campus living yeah
thank you thank you Julie and Kelsey
um Allah
wanted also to thank you so much protein
for the presentation
um really valuable information the
panelists for the great Insight
um I was wondering is there another time
where the program is offered as well as
for example on the references if you
don't have an entrepreneurial skills uh
what other than your Innovation skills
really should the reference not their
touch alone
yeah so the reference
um doesn't have to talk about your
Innovation skills if that's just not
something that they have insight into
that will be something I believe it's
one of the questions that is asked in
the recommendation form but somebody who
can speak to who you are as a student or
a colleague
um or you know a teammate
really just an outside perspective on on
you in a professional type of setting is
is great and that can be somebody you
work with or somebody that you know
outside of you know worker studies who
you feel can really speak to that aspect
of you
foreign
offered
um at another time in during the year
other than the summer yes there's also
the part-time program in the winter so
that's actually just wrap that up um is
January um early January through early
March so eight weeks part-time so
Tuesday Thursday evenings from six to
nine pm and then Saturdays from roughly
nine to four A.M
and that one is the same curriculum just
spread out into a different schedule
typically better designed to suit
working professionals and folks who
can't you know step back from their job
or their studies for a month at a time
hi everyone my name is Eugene I'm
currently a master's student at Stanford
I'm wondering for all of you who have
participated in the program what are
your favorite classes at ignite
well I can start like if no one goes uh
I will say about one favorite class and
one favorite and then maybe one favorite
Professor there was one specific
Professor the
Jonathan levav uh I think uh maybe type
in so he remembered them uh him I'm
sorry uh he was a marketing professor
and he he taught us a class on how to
think inside the box that was the title
of the like uh the slideshow and
actually was him talking about the
Frameworks of marketing that you have to
have uh when you're thinking about
generating an idea because part of the
program is generating ideas and making
sure that you develop part of it like
the ideation part of it and that was a
very amazing class I think most of the
class the students were like wow this
professor in this class is so Stanford
and this is so what we needed to think
about and he was very charismatic
charismatic as well and another one that
I would say most because of the core
skill of the class was uh business model
from Professor medicine it was a very
nice class for me helped a lot in terms
of frameworking uh I'm someone who works
with that with uh like creating products
and thinking about new opportunities in
the market a specific niche of the
market so it was very important for me
to think about like profit model uh
business model what exactly you have to
use to think about when you're thinking
about launching a product in the market
so I would say both of them
timer so here don't let me standing yeah
and
um my third class took place during the
power outage that we had we went we went
and I remember Professor yossi giving us
this trading simulation game it was like
one of my favorite classes and he hits
the point on um on the on the
competitive theory in economics I think
that's what it's called correct me if
I'm wrong and I also loved professors
wobble's entrepreneurial class on where
we could the most important thing in
startups is how could you raise money
how much cash should we have so just
laying it out in a very simplified way
that any person with no Finance
background with no business background
could easily understand uh that was one
of my favorite class even it was a
favorite class of mines
so they all took place at during a time
where there was no power at campus but I
enjoyed those moments
so it is interesting to me that my
favorite class is different from your
different classes so the one that I
liked was I'm not sure if the name I
remember it correctly but it was I think
acting with power
something similar to that towards the
end of the program
and what we were learning there was that
the role that you have in your company
for example
uh has some requirements that might be
different from your actual character so
sometimes you need to be very assertive
sometimes not
some you know when you deal with
different people in a company in the
organization you need to assume some
role for yourself and that person
and you need to play that role in order
for the company to function properly
and this was taught to us through some
different games between us yeah this was
mind-blowing to me that's very
interesting
what other questions can be concerned
right there's a question in the chat
um since the program starts after
graduation can International students
who are at Stanford on F1 visas apply
does ignite require special visa to
attend
um does it interfere with opt so
um
yes typically the program dates fit
within the kind of buffer window on
student Visas so in the past I've had a
number of folks who participated right
after graduating and the ignite program
developed and before they their visa was
up we don't require specific Visa ignite
is not eligible for student Visas so if
you are traveling to to the US for the
ignite program you would need to travel
on probably a tourist visa if you you
know are planning to be conducting work
while you're here it may be that there's
a business Visa that would also make
sense for you but most International
folks come on a tourist visa to
participate in ignite
yes um Julia if you have advice
um on the Visa arrival process
um yeah I had this kind of little issue
when I arrived I had no admissions in my
cell phone and the offer server was like
no you should have it printed and I was
like
but I have it here and it was kind of
hard but it eventually it worked out but
so so you don't have this type of
problem just print it out if you get
admitted yeah
we have time for a couple more questions
um so go ahead and feel free to raise
your hand or unmute or type something
into the chat
um ah I am a student and I have a
co-founder who's not she's awesome can
she apply and can we work in a cohort
um so yeah if you have
um if you have a co-founder who you are
working with you're welcome to both
apply to the program there's no
guarantee that you will both be admitted
but we have had you know pairs of people
attend together in the past and if you
do have a co-founder and you both are
indignant together and your idea becomes
a team yossi and I will be sure to put
you both on the same team together
if it's a much larger group or you
couldn't have like six people all apply
to ignite together and then all form a
team together but like a single
co-founder or colleague we can make that
happen
while we're waiting in the last couple
questions something that people
sometimes ask about is intellectual
property so just wanted to mention that
the ignite doesn't gain any ownership of
any of the ideas that are brought up in
the program if you have a venture idea
that you bring into ignite at the end of
the program it will still be yours
there's no ownership change of your
intellectual property as a result of
participating in ignite
there are some teams that choose to you
know bring kind of some folks will bring
an idea in and choose to bring some of
their ignite classmates in as
co-founders and then they work out their
own agreement on ownership I keep that
kind of thing but that only happens in
the instances where
a group of participants independently
decide to move forward as a company
after events
um yes is it recruited business cigar
a question so I'm like uh if we if I
want to like you know apply for ignite
and you know if I I'm not from Stanford
like you know uh is there any are there
any kind of like you know mentorships
that are mentors that are available as
Stanford or you know how to uh do the
application process and know what to
learn what not to include uh you know
for the best chances
um so we don't have any official kind of
mentors or resources like
that
that what the admissions committee is
typically looking for is that you have a
clear that you have a clear reason why
you need ignite like so why ignite why
right now
um and that you have a plan for how
you're going to use what you learn and
ignite or why you feel that this will
really benefit you in your career
um so having that Clear Vision and
knowing why you're applying is important
and then also your drive in Innovation
or entrepreneurship or you know in that
space
as well as a passion you know and being
able to demonstrate that you're
passionate about whatever it is that you
work on
in your essays and or your interview
because at the end of the day that's
written for are innovators who are
driven and excited about what they're
working on
okay cool thank you
I'd like to add on to that uh as
teamwork
you should be a team player you're gonna
be put into a group where you have to
and it's an equal group it was we were
six so you need to be a team player you
need to know how to manage a team and
move you're going to disagree a lot I
think surveillance
we were put into different teams and it
was just this agreements disagreements
debates and it's not going to end to it
there and it's not going to end to a
point until you as a team just reach a
consensus so you have to be a team
player so that's
really important before applying just
see how you used to how how were you in
a team and what were your skills how
were you able to manage a team I think
this was a really important part during
the program
and one thing that I want to add to tell
your boss point is that people that are
in this program are intentionally from
diverse backgrounds so when you are in a
team that you know has people that
fundamentally think differently
right and
that's much harder you know compared to
the teams that we usually do homeworks
with right
so yeah
um you know the more diverse your
background the better but be prepared to
deal with you know real situations that
happen for real startups
okay cool thank you
and how do you form the team do you get
assigned or do you choose your own team
we everyone has an opportunity to submit
an idea
um within the first week and a half or
so of that pre-programmed period and
then
um on the first day of the program the
most popular of those ideas will have a
chance to talk and you'll get to ask
questions and really formulate your
ranking of typically about 20 ideas and
then yossi and I form people into teams
based on your preferences
so
it's not that you truly get to choose
your team if 12 people all request the
same idea you know only six of them are
going to get it but we'll then try to
make sure that everyone is on one of
their top typically three choices so our
goal is to optimize everyone getting
onto a team that they want
um
and all the ideas are fully submitted by
by you by participants so it's entirely
kind of up to you all as a cohort what
ideas move forward and what projects get
worked on as teams
sounds good
so on that if I could have a suggestion
is that even if you think your idea
might not become a startup I suggest
that you just submit your idea because
that becomes a talking point in the
first few days and you will find people
that have similar mindset
right and many of the ideas that were
submitted
you know they were similar right and
people after ignite
they are connected to each other and
they work on the similar subjects right
um
and you know you're experience in ignite
depends a lot on whether or not you're
passionate about your team and your
subject
just even like to
add on to sohailers don't get too
attached to your startup idea
pivot it's a place where You're
vulnerable you can make mistakes learn
from the ideas don't just get too
attached because everyone comes in
thinking that's this is their startup
there is Market validation and then when
you go in you notice that it's not the
way you think it is so you have to learn
how to Pivot you're gonna see hurdles on
the way even though if your ideas pass
Professor yossi is going to teach you
specific Frameworks when it comes to
implementation
doesn't your your your pro your the way
you used to think about your startup
begins to change and I've seen that
during the program people started off
with their ideas and they actually
during presentations it was like a
different type of uh I think Julia she
could add on to this it was like a
different uh ending to their startup so
I could just just be open it's an area
where you could just be vulnerable have
fun with it so that's the end the
outcome that you want to reach to post
igniters just enjoy the process enjoy
the learning process
yeah I couldn't agree more I think uh
both like pretty much the advice is is a
it's an opportunity for you to self-roll
and self-develop as a profession and as
a person so and that's pretty much what
I think Stanford's for like I don't know
you so he was there another in another
um uh school but anyways and most of you
have coming from from Stanford at
different schools but in the end of the
day it's more like how you develop
yourself you develop your idea uh using
diversity the good part of diversity is
that like sahil said you have all these
diverse backgrounds in mind think mind's
thinking together but it's not very good
if you get very strong convictions
because with convictions you can't
actually profit and benefit from the
diversity involved so I think that's the
opportunity we completely changed our
our project actually we are now some the
idea generator is running the project
still and we have shifted it again I
help her sell so it's it's a pretty nice
opportunity for you to grow and and
develop yourself and your product and
your idea while you're there and the
years that the months that are that are
to come
so we're just about a time before we
wrap up panelists is there any are there
any final thoughts you'd like to share
advice you have
um or anything else you'd like to share
before we wrap up our meeting today
I just wanted to say like the the
curriculum and the things that we
actually learned throughout Stanford
ignite is the exact same thing I do at
my job so it's a real life example how
we analyze startups Ventures what we
look for is the exact same framework
you're gonna learn at ignite
just that's that's my advice is like
really no
what your your what what what Professor
you will see in the Stanford faculty are
teaching you and just try to have an
open mind and ask questions and your
your and Stanford ignite is also you are
lucky if you get admitted why because
you're getting like a pre startup
session where you have a mentors you
have communication coaches and then you
have VCS actual VC Partners managing
partners coming in and giving you their
honest opinions and constructive
feedback so just utilize it leverage
that and leverage your relationships
during the program that's the most
important thing like the final takeaway
I have
um my final takeaways or my final words
are that
have tried to be very proactive in
ignite so you have one month and you
have
too many opportunities to use them all
right that's try to you know use your
mentors try to get connected with all of
the people that are ignite because those
are the people that have similar passion
as you and now the course material is
very very good
but even more valuable than that are the
connections other people
you set it out for me the file takeaway
is your final takeaway relationships and
self-growth yeah
well I think
um thank you all for joining um
panelists in particular thank you so
much for coming and sharing the
first-hand experience of being in the
ignite program
um for everyone else uh thanks again for
joining us this evening a recording will
be shared within the next week or so and
I look forward to seeing all of your
applications in the coming month you're
always welcome to reach out if you have
any questions about the program or the
application process and I'll be happy to
help
um best of luck and hope to meet you in
person this summer